INDICTMENT INVOLVING HIS EFFORTS
TOVEN THE ELECTION RESULTS SRUO
DTOY LA H
D WURULIO
E TE T ROC RNIASTE
S.--S  IHEEAONUM
UM"T F--- O
AINDIAIMCRS  I CI TAB,FO, TH AE
HER POBONAOU IFOIN B I>>ONR IGEO
RIY REALT Y .NLET DOTS
JOD TE S FYEL W,M SEE DDR
WOH ONIOOKOU ON D HAHEKEERTA TYI
OF THI WALO FIILUPE  MUP LIVITN
URPR  TAKNG TAS S NTVE ARDLUYOTS
L N GHL IDWAICLEEFANH LDANHIG UN
LFDOI ORD T RY BMECKKIY
D UN
W IPRNADO S -TRHEG  TEH.NGPEY S
N'LE .YOU TIHEREST
T NIGT , D UANS IM,  WLD T WRV
ARAB T WLTATRI AN W RS
D R  VHALEHE RUFEEFIHTOF
THSHTAE DOLYRUANIMBALAIC
DEGH C A TD YO WOPUTEL'S       T
-LPEINWAT ANVEHOMONT GONMPL,NSME
E JEINTYITT.THOIFIOOILINREYONIR
IC OCN TAG H
S
ODAN G D A OE  B.ELOUR S HANGAN
AIFE M T S
L.IDITR ON
AT  TEN.W,IOOFS AV
TA OMPEN'SHE
ERIO IOFN
TT'S H H
HA
TOECS AV, AMURYOSTGEITYOEDIMMA
HEEPPERASEVEOTTO
LDU HE ASEAG I
T SN
ON GSE J
NOCTCOEXLETHHENGRSKS HAC.E U GHE
OCRE
'SK
IDO UC AALO T IBAY ER TT THL UT
REN ENYODO HO , NOOP
EAK E
'SFO TORGENO  W GTTNSLE AAVYBE
BEFOPLN N U'IC S'SU
G L T
IS WOTF ATM  DOR ROP
L  L
,
TA
SEER WMB
RO YAC
N HA, E
REDE'TRDNLEHIME'TGIHA
CTCUSSE E  DT  IE UNISI' COWITH
P,L.EYY GA
T KEALDO
T THBYNGHIS
ALS.G HIFAE TI HD
E AN
SPINAB- LEMEVEHOANSEDE T D
U S N T, STH
ONNY- >>GOK.NDN STPA
HEPA S
OCD AFITITAN, HOTOF .S SIDAE PO
SO ETUBUSETTE,ARREK OC GCAUIIK O
YM G IDSE WA VECHO OT
APOETIHE L HTHINISED TN  T L SO
H E
HKAAYIMINNKCE J AEC HLEGED ANDS
IFO, P EYTEF F KNAS>>KNTHOU -ON
YEAS 'S AHIUMNG"  YNGAKADVE.
HA
PEATRNED
I D SERTUNGWAAST AVNTY ESTHEN.F
REL
ITDOOUCCCOUTOUHE
NTN
NDS S Y END,DONGMA
WAD  WFIRENO TESW ISCEOUHE     N
EPUNLERSTH LATH
S HECK AEI
E HAE WS OLL
ER, . AMND
ANND TCAAV AFOT
ANY'RAENVEOESSNOANHI
S S  J I
PI, DCOKLD M TATKEHI S
I
P S SANTSTHISRI
NT'TRYT TONEATR OSWH, RMRDHI S.C
ETU TLIILNGW,T Y YOT TA
NG>>F
AYT'T ROCIJUCIE S EDENME YMEOPTY
RO ITHAT
YTHANOUNTJELENOGHIKS  THO L S I
G  THI
>> OS
ESIVHIO .AHNTRETYAN>>T TS OP WE
L O  S, HIERUNHIWAAREREVE ER T I
CHNDTHTO HIN.NKE.NEFONKS DY
ANSEWE.HA
T.RE PTHT  W PBYURCH
D KETH.
OBE LDEE UUM'S'SN OFHEINULCAOFOP
E  PAR
TEERYW TYOEDWO SHOED
?GHFT,CA
UNRSWYEI NDMATA YS MPATIS
CTT, TOU